bon résumons tu accusé d'avoir servi de
l'alcool à une mineure de trafic de
drogue soit 408 bout la seaco fasse les
bons derniers investisseurs a perdu la
tête
je crois pas l'avoir perdue picard et
plus pour combler car on va pas mettre
plein les poches les gaz battront les
données je crois qu'on a un petit
problème
[Musique]
dites moi où je peux trouver crime avec
les amis sont une sorte de famille sur
la mort des célébrités qui david
hasselhoff l'heure il gagne un demi
million dollar cash flow dessus l'heure
est venue de tuer pour gagner l'argent
du paris ça ça n'a absolument aucun sens
non mais tu dois le rhum et d'hommes
politiques à ne pas mélanger avec du jus
de pamplemousse
ça peut causer une réaction
[Musique]
donc vous attendu pour secourir le
secteur non seulement à la télévision
mais enfin pourquoi il faut
[Musique]
vous allez bien compris ce qu'on attend
go une fan de david hasselhoff est ce
que je fais tu où est ce que je te fais
langoureuse mon avis n'a pas notre joie
[Musique]
on n'a jamais dit qu'il ne fallait pas
faire chier à c'est l'or
là c'est un scénario que j'aime rêver
[Musique]